lo hice porque él estaba engañando al
público
trate de matarlo
y lo mejor que pude
Esta es la confesión del hombre que
atentó contra la vida del Primer
Ministro pakistaní in Ram
el atentado se llevó a cabo mientras
Khan protagonizaba desde el pasado
viernes lo que denomina como una gran
marcha contra la injerencia extranjera
horas después del ataque el secretario
general del partido del político fue
portador de un mensaje suyo inram estaba
advertido
que hiciéramos una declaración en su
nombre dijo que tenía información previa
de la que no estábamos al tanto de que
estaba seguro de que tres personas lo
habían atacado y esas tres personas son
el Primer Ministro Rivas yarif el
ministro del interior rana sana y el
General de división dijo que tenía esta
información desde antes y sobre esta
base estaba afirmando que el ataque
contra él fue realizado por ellos su
exigencia es que estos tres sean
removidos de sus cargos sino son
despedidos de sus cargos entonces habrá
protestas en todo el país
sin embargo uno de los acusados rechazó
de manera rotunda lo sucedido condenó el
hecho de disparar contra el presidente
del pti infrancamp con las palabras más
enérgicas le he pedido al ministro del
interior un informe inmediato sobre el
incidente rezo por la recuperación y la
salud del presidente del pti y otras
personas heridas
partidarios del ex Primer Ministro y ex
Astro del cricket salieron a las calles
a manifestarse contra la agresión
llegó al poder en las elecciones
generales de 2018 y posteriormente de
puesto en una moción de censura en abril
de este año el alega que fue un castigo
planeado en Washington por su visita
Moscú el primer día de la invasión rusa
Ucrania Pakistán tiene antecedentes de
violencia política el más reciente se
suma al asesinato de la ex primera
ministra de nacer voto en el año 2007